the president's own words maybe
complicating the legal case for his
travel ban in Twitter messages yesterday
he took aim at the courts his own
Justice Department and the revised ban
he tweeted this we need a travel ban for
certain dangerous countries not some
politically correct term that won't help
us protect our people mr. Trump's focus
on the ban is also distracting attention
from his infrastructure proposals
Margaret Brennan is at the White House
with the latest Margaret good morning
good morning while President Trump meets
today with congressional leaders about
health care and tax reform this is part
of a White House effort to keep the
president focused on his own agenda
we're still stuck with an ancient broken
antiquated horrible system that doesn't
work the president's focus on Monday was
supposed to be on reforming air traffic
control part of his week-long initiative
to overhaul the nation's infrastructure
but the president had his eye on other
targets including reviving his Court
suspended temporary freeze on travel
from six muslim-majority countries in a
series of tweets the president insisted
on calling it a travel ban and dismissed
the federal court objections as simply a
matter of political correctness mr.
Trump's comments prompted attorney
George Conway husband of white house
councilor Kellyanne Conway to tweet a
rare public rebuke the president's post
may make some people feel better Conway
wrote but they won't help get five votes
in the Supreme Court which is what
actually matters sad Donald J Trump is
calling for a total and complete
shutdown of Muslims entering the United
States the president's own language
Monday contradicts his lawyers who have
emphasized it is just a temporary pause
not a ban and insisted is not aimed at
Muslims this is not I repeat not a ban
on Muslims well first of all it's not a
travel ban federal courts have doubted
that and suspended the president's
executive order citing the backdrop of
public statements by the president and
his advisors yesterday White House
spokesman Sarah Sanders tried to
downplay the discrepancy
I don't think the president cares what
you call it whether you call it a band
whether you call it a restriction
President Trump also continued to feud
with the Mayor of London Sadiq Khan
whose public statements the president
characterized as pathetic Khan suggested
mr. Trump is no longer welcome in London
I don't think we should roll out the red
carpet to the President of the USA in
the circumstances where his policies go
against everything we stand for
that's not the only distraction
yesterday the White House legislative
affairs director admitted that having
Congress focused on the Russia probe
detracts from the Trump administration's
agenda Norah that's making it harder for
them to achieve their goals all right
Margaret thank you so much